Is this the first time you're writing, like, production Rust Code? Yeah, I'm actually writing Rust Code now. So what's your experience? I mean, this is going to, this could be a very hot news for the orange websites of the world. You know, the C++ Luminary, Sean Parent's thoughts on working day-to-day with Rust. You better be careful. They're going to take away your keynote from the CPPN to the C. I know.
这是你第一次编写生产级的 Rust 代码吗？是的，我现在确实在写 Rust 代码。那么你的体验如何？我的意思是，这对全世界的“橙色网站”来说可能是一个非常重磅的新闻。你知道，C++ 泰斗 Sean Parent 对日常使用 Rust 的看法。你最好小心点，他们会取消你在 CppCon 上的主题演讲的。我知道。
I've got this keynote, and I'm like, yeah, I'm not doing much in C++ anymore. Takes on Rust. There's a lot to like. Now, are you writing this rest code with directly or are you using AI? I am certainly using AI. I mean, one of the great things that I have found with Cursor and Claude, I'm in kind of the Conner camp here. It's rocket fuel.
我接到了这个主题演讲，我当时想，是的，我不再怎么写 C++ 了。关于 Rust 的看法，有很多值得喜欢的地方。那么，你是直接编写这些 Rust 代码，还是在使用 AI？我当然在使用 AI。我的意思是，我在 Cursor 和 Claude 上发现的一大优点是，我属于 Connor 阵营。这简直是火箭燃料。
Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode. 252 recorded on August 21st, 2025. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we chat with Sean Parent about Rust and AI. There was an audible sigh from Sean after Bryce complaining about Gemini's integration with his email. Feel free to follow up that sigh with your thoughts and feeling, Sean. It's just the unpredictable nature of AI.
欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第 252 期，录制于 2025 年 8 月 21 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起，与 Sean Parent 聊聊 Rust 和 AI。在 Bryce 抱怨 Gemini 与他的电子邮件集成后，Sean 发出了一声明显的叹息。Sean，欢迎你接着那声叹息，谈谈你的想法和感受。这只是 AI 不可预测的本质。
Oh, we were just, so we were talking about this earlier that I was telling Connor that I feel like we both are doing the AI coding thing and we're both big proponents of it. But I feel like Connor's experience is a lot cheery where I have what Connor is calling the, Connor's vibe coding, I'm rage coding, where I'm like, oh, you stupid robot, why would you do that? And it's like, I know it's not a person, but it's still, it feels like it's intentionally being incompetent. It feels like it's personally, like I feel personally wounded every time it does something, you know, silly. And it's like I can't, I can't overcome this desire to, it's like the worst thing where like it makes a mistake instead of me just being like, all right, I'll just tell it to correct the mistake. I'm like, explain yourself. You tell me why. Why did you not listen to my instructions?
哦，我们刚才还在谈论这个，我告诉 Connor，我觉得我们都在进行 AI 编程，而且我们都是它的坚定支持者。但我觉得 Connor 的体验要愉快得多，而我处于 Connor 所说的“氛围编程”状态，我是在“愤怒编程”，我会说，哦，你这个愚蠢的机器人，你为什么要那样做？我知道它不是一个人，但它仍然感觉像是故意表现得无能。每次它做一些愚蠢的事情时，我都感觉自己受到了个人伤害，你知道吗？我无法克服这种欲望，最糟糕的是，当它犯错时，我本可以告诉它纠正错误，但我却说，解释一下你自己。你告诉我为什么。为什么你不听我的指令？
Well, something I've had recently good luck with in Cursor is to say, say you keep doing, you know, X. So please create a prompt for yourself. That will have the rule set, so you will stop. And sometimes it'll create like, you know, I had like a one-sentence thing. I told it to stop doing it, and it will create five paragraphs. And it's like, okay, now it works.
嗯，我最近在 Cursor 上运气不错，我会说，假设你一直做某事，请为自己创建一个提示词。这会设定规则，这样你就会停止。有时它会创建，你知道，我有一个一句话的要求，我告诉它停止这样做，它会创建五个段落。然后，好吧，现在它起作用了。
Like, that's what it took. Wow. What do you call that? Like bootstrapped context engineering? Yeah. I tried something like that where I asked Cursor to write a cursor role for itself. But as it turns out probably intelligently that they have blocked Cursor from writing from modifying the cursor roles,
就像，这就是它所需要的。哇。你管那叫什么？引导式上下文工程？是的。我尝试过类似的事情，我要求 Cursor 为自己编写一个 Cursor 规则。但事实证明，他们很聪明地阻止了 Cursor 修改 Cursor 规则，
which I guess is a sensible thing to do. Yes, it can't modify them, but it can put it in the text that you're going to copy and paste into one. So, yeah. Sometimes I'm a little frightened by the lack of guards as it's like, here's this massive mumbo-jumbo. Execute that in the terminal.
我想这是一种明智的做法。是的，它不能修改它们，但它可以把内容放在文本里，让你复制粘贴进去。所以，是的。有时我被缺乏防护措施吓到了，它就像是，这是这一大堆乱七八糟的东西。在终端执行它。
You're like, really? Wait, wait, wait. Actually, I have a, before we start delving into the details and weeds, because we haven't talked to Sean in a while, let's, well, because I'm curious to get you mentioned cursor, but we'll, we'll put that question on the back burner. The first question, how have you been? We haven't chatted in a while. I know, I think one of the topics we'll get to is you are keynoting at C++ under the C if I'm not mistaken, which by the time the listeners are listening to this should be in roughly, I think, a month from now, because this will come out in early September. So anyways, how have you been? We'll talk about the upcoming keynote, and then, yeah, we'll take some time. Because I did see that on GitHub, because I follow you. At one point, you pushed a commit or a PR that was updating the documentation of something. And it said explicitly in the details, like, thanks to Claude or something like that.
你会想，真的吗？等等，等等。其实，在我们开始深入细节之前，因为我们有一段时间没和 Sean 聊天了，我想，因为我很好奇你提到了 Cursor，但我们会把那个问题先搁置一下。第一个问题，你最近怎么样？我们有一段时间没聊了。我知道，我想我们要谈的话题之一是你将在 CppCon 上做主题演讲，如果我没记错的话，到听众听到这个节目时，应该大约在一个月后，因为这期节目会在九月初发布。总之，你最近怎么样？我们会谈谈即将到来的主题演讲，然后，是的，我们会花点时间。因为我确实在 GitHub 上看到了，因为我关注你。有一次，你推送了一个提交或 PR，更新了某样东西的文档。它在细节里明确写着，感谢 Claude 之类的。
And I was like, all right, people have been asking to have you back on the pod. But also, we got to get, you know, someone who's a little bit more senior than Bryce and I, their thought on, you know, the age of AI coding. But anyways, how have you been? I've been doing well, yeah, keeping busy. Let's see, probably since last time we talked, I stepped back from managing, so I'm no longer STLAB manager here. I handed those reins off to David Sankle.
我当时想，好吧，人们一直要求让你回到播客。而且，我们也得找一个比 Bryce 和我资历更深的人，听听他们对 AI 编程时代的看法。但总之，你最近怎么样？我一直很好，是的，一直很忙。让我们看看，大概从我们上次谈话以来，我退出了管理岗位，所以我不再是这里的 STLAB 经理了。我把那些职责交给了 David Sankle。
I heard that in a talk that he gave. He said that you, like, Jedi mind-tricked him into, like, giving him what he wanted, but, like, you also, in order to get what you want, must become manager. Yes, a couple times in my career, I've hired my own manager, so it's worked out well. Yeah, so I'm coding and writing. Dave Abrams and I are working on the book, which is moving, but slowly. This is the better code book. This is the better code book that I announced and have had a contract with Pearson since 2014,
我在他的一次演讲中听到了。他说你像绝地武士一样诱导他，让他得到了他想要的，但为了得到你想要的，他也必须成为经理。是的，在我的职业生涯中，我有几次雇佣了我自己的经理，所以效果很好。是的，所以我现在在写代码和写作。Dave Abrams 和我正在写那本书，进展缓慢。这就是《Better Code》那本书。这是我宣布并自 2014 年以来一直与 Pearson 签有合同的《Better Code》书，
so we're a little more than a decade late. But it will happen eventually. I don't know if it will matter at this point because AI is changing everything. Well, I mean, the book might be helpful for the AI. I know. That's what David and I keep saying. It's like, you might be writing this for the last reader, right? So that's going along.
所以我们迟到了十年多。但它最终会完成的。我不知道到那时它是否还有意义，因为 AI 正在改变一切。嗯，我的意思是，这本书对 AI 可能有帮助。我知道。这就是 David 和我一直说的。就像，你可能是在为最后一位读者写这本书，对吧？所以进展还行。
We also, you know, the first software technology lab, which was with Steppenoff and Paul McJones and Matt Marcus and Foster Burriton. One of our big projects was a couple of libraries. The most important one, I think, was the property model library, which is also known as Adam. It's still kicking around. It's part of ASL out there.
我们还有，你知道，第一个软件技术实验室，那是和 Steppenoff、Paul McJones、Matt Marcus 和 Foster Burriton 一起建立的。我们的大项目之一是几个库。我认为最重要的是属性模型库，也称为 Adam。它仍然存在。它是 ASL 的一部分。
And it was always part of a larger vision, which is how do we move past imperative coding into a world where we can stay in tents and have the system solve for it under the hood. And so property model libraries or property models are a constrained constraint system where you can specify relationships between discrete properties, and then the library will solve for them. And so it typically gets used for using building UIs where you want to specify constraints and relationships around arguments to some operation. And then you can bind a U.I against that model, and then you get a functioning U.I.
它一直是一个更大愿景的一部分，那就是我们如何超越命令式编程，进入一个我们可以保持意图，并让系统在底层解决问题的世界。所以属性模型库或属性模型是一个约束系统，你可以在其中指定离散属性之间的关系，然后库会为它们求解。它通常用于构建 UI，你想要指定围绕某些操作参数的约束和关系。然后你可以将 UI 绑定到该模型上，你就会得到一个功能性的 UI。
So when you check on this checkbox, that checkbox over there gets disabled, not because there's any code that says when this is on, disable that. it's because the rules around disablement are when an item is either implied by something else in the system or disconnected in the system. It should be disabled. And so it becomes a much more compact and has a bunch of proofs around it, a way to describe behaviors. So our team has resurrected basically that project and the expanded vision of it as something we call project less. And there's a lot of no-code, low-code systems out there. But the vision here is to try to build a low-code environment where you describe large systems in terms of intent, and the system constructs from that models, and you get an executing application and do it in a scalable
所以当你勾选这个复选框时，那边的复选框就会被禁用，不是因为有任何代码说当这个开启时，禁用那个。而是因为禁用的规则是当一个项目被系统中的其他东西暗示或在系统中断开连接时。它应该被禁用。所以它变得更加紧凑，并且围绕它有一堆证明，一种描述行为的方式。所以我们的团队基本上复活了那个项目，并将其扩展的愿景称为 Project Less。外面有很多无代码、低代码系统。但这里的愿景是尝试构建一个低代码环境，你用意图来描述大型系统，系统从中构建模型，你得到一个可执行的应用程序，并以可扩展的形式完成它。
form. And we're writing that in Rust, so I've been working on the underlying run-back system for that in Rust. It doesn't sound like you're coming, well, you're coming back to the project from an idea standpoint, but not from an implementation standpoint. My guess is that the initial iteration of this was in C++, and this time you're doing it in Rust. Yeah, the initial implementation of this was in C++, and, you know, it's been used at Adobe for 20 years now. You know, so we have lots of experience with it. And, you know, there are some common issues that have come up around the ergonomics of the system, you know, insights into being able to see what the actual structure is that gets built for a given declaration. The previous system was dynamically typed.
我们正在用 Rust 编写它，所以我一直在用 Rust 开发底层的运行系统。听起来你不是，嗯，你是从想法的角度回到这个项目，而不是从实现的角度。我猜这个的最初迭代是在 C++ 中，而这次你是在用 Rust 做。是的，这个的最初实现是在 C++ 中，你知道，它在 Adobe 已经使用了 20 年了。你知道，所以我们在这方面有很多经验。而且，你知道，围绕系统的工效学出现了一些常见问题，你知道，洞察力，能够看到为给定声明构建的实际结构是什么。之前的系统是动态类型的。
And now there are various act solutions to try to retrofit schemas on top of it. so you can verify things that compile time instead of having them fail at runtime. And so then the new system that I'm working on is statically typed and kind of from the ground up and has much better facilities for introspection and much better error reporting.
现在有各种解决方案试图在它之上加装模式。这样你就可以在编译时验证事物，而不是让它们在运行时失败。所以，我正在开发的新系统是静态类型的，是从零开始的，并且有更好的内省设施和更好的错误报告。
So trying to address all of those issues. So it's a full rethink and rewrite. And is this the first time you're writing like production Rust Code? I imagine you've dabbled in it before, but I don't recall chatting with you saying that, oh, yeah, we're doing, you've mentioned libraries at Adobe,
所以试图解决所有这些问题。所以这是一个彻底的反思和重写。这是你第一次编写生产级的 Rust 代码吗？我想你以前可能涉猎过，但我记不起和你聊天时你说过，哦，是的，我们正在做，你提到过 Adobe 的库，
but I thought that was, you always were referring to them as a project somewhere else, but it sounds like you're actually writing Rust Code now. Yeah, I'm actually writing Rust Code now. So what's your experience? I mean, this is going to, this could be a very hot news for the orange websites of the world, you know, the C++ Luminary,
但我以为那是，你总是把它们称为其他地方的项目，但听起来你现在确实在写 Rust 代码。是的，我现在确实在写 Rust 代码。那么你的体验如何？我的意思是，这对全世界的“橙色网站”来说可能是一个非常重磅的新闻，你知道，C++ 泰斗，
Sean Parent's thoughts on working day-to-day with Rust. You better be careful. They're going to take away your keynote from the CPP under the C. I know. I've got this keynote, and I'm like, yeah, I'm not doing much in C++ anymore, which isn't quite true. I've been spending, I spent my morning here working on C++ libraries. But it takes on Rust.
Sean Parent 对日常使用 Rust 的看法。你最好小心点。他们会取消你在 CppCon 上的主题演讲的。我知道。我接到了这个主题演讲，我当时想，是的，我不再怎么写 C++ 了，这其实不太准确。我一直在花时间，我今天早上在这里花时间编写 C++ 库。但关于 Rust 的看法。
There's a lot to like. One of the things I really like about Rust is the tooling and the set of environment and, you know, cargo for doing package management. And the fact that unit tests are directly in your source. files along with documentation tests, and in Cloud or VS code, you can just click on the test to execute it and, you know, run things directly in your IDE and build your documentation and view it. And so all of that is just so much easier to get set up in cargo. And then from a language standpoint, there's a lot to like about it. There's a lot of things they got
有很多值得喜欢的地方。我真正喜欢 Rust 的一点是它的工具和环境设置，你知道，用于包管理的 Cargo。而且单元测试直接在你的源文件中，还有文档测试，在 Claude 或 VS Code 中，你可以直接点击测试来执行它，你知道，直接在你的 IDE 中运行事物并构建你的文档并查看它。所以所有这些在 Cargo 中设置起来都容易得多。然后从语言的角度来看，有很多值得喜欢的地方。有很多他们做对的事情。
right. Destructive move as the default. are explicit and usually not necessary, so it's not like a reference semantic language, you know, like Python or things like that, so you can write efficient code. They don't have production co-routines. You know, their co-routines are in nightly built.
默认的破坏性移动。是显式的，通常是不必要的，所以它不像引用语义语言，你知道，像 Python 之类的，所以你可以编写高效的代码。他们没有生产级的协程。你知道，他们的协程在 nightly 构建中。
They do have kind of a partial implementation of co-routines that they use for async and await. But even at that level, their co-routines or function objects of that level are just objects, unlike in in C++, where you get this implied heap allocation and type erasure that goes on with co-routines,
他们确实有一种用于 async 和 await 的协程的部分实现。但即使在那个层面上，他们的协程或那个层面的函数对象也只是对象，不像在 C++ 中，你会得到这种隐含的堆分配和类型擦除，
and so co-routines become fairly heavyweight. The fact that void, which is just the empty tuple in Rust, is regular, cleans up so much code. So that's all. What do you not like about Rust? Well, you said that those are the things that you think they're doing right. What are the things you think they're doing wrong? There is no specialization in Rust. So if I have a, for example, in C++, you get used to this notion of you've got forward
所以协程变得相当沉重。void（在 Rust 中只是空元组）是常规的，这清理了大量的代码。所以就是这样。你不喜欢 Rust 的什么？嗯，你说那些是你认为他们做对的事情。你认为他们做错的事情是什么？Rust 中没有特化。所以如果我有一个，例如，在 C++ 中，你习惯了这种概念，你有前向迭代器、双向迭代器和随机访问迭代器，它们每一个都特化了另一个，对吧？所以随机迭代器比前向迭代器更特化。如果我用前向迭代器编写算法，并且我调用了一些如果它是随机访问迭代器可以更有效地完成的事情，而我恰好有一个随机访问迭代器，它会调用特化的函数，我会得到更优的路径。Rust 没有这个？Rust 没有这个。但他们有运算符重载，对吧？
iterators and bidirectional iterators and random access iterators, and those each specialize the other one, right? So random iterator is more specialized than just a forward iterator. And if I'm writing an algorithm in terms of forward iterators and I call some, something that could be done more efficiently if it's a random access iterator, and I happen to have a random access iterator, it will call the specialized function and I'll get the more optimal path. Rust doesn't have this? Rust does not have this. But they have like operator overloading, right?
他们没有直接的运算符重载。他们通过 trait 来实现，这并不坏。但语法极其冗长。你知道，总的来说，Rust 的语法甚至比 C++ 更糟糕，这令人难以置信，因为 C++ 的语法已经够糟糕了。你知道，但在 Rust 中，就像，哦，我想创建一个类。在 C++ 中，我可以创建一个类并在其中内联我所有的成员函数。如果我有正确的一组成员函数，那么它可能符合某些概念。而且，你知道，我不必声明符合性在 C++ 中是有问题的。
They do not have operator overloading directly. They have it through traits, which isn't bad. But the syntax is incredibly verbose. You know, in Rust in general, the syntax is even worse than C++, which is unbelievable because C++'s syntax is so horrible. You know, but in Rust, it's like, oh, I want to create a class. And in C++, I could create a class and in line all of my member functions in it. And if I have the right set of member functions, then that might conform to some concept. and, you know, the fact that I don't have to declare conformance is problematic in C++.
但事实上，我可以把所有东西写在一个单元里是很好的。而在 Rust 中，我必须说，好吧，我有一个结构体，我的结构体只有数据成员，没有方法。然后我必须写一个单独的块，那是该结构体的实现，提供了我类上的方法。然后我想说，哦，这个东西要，你知道，符合一个 trait。好吧，我必须说我正在为我的类实现这个 trait，然后我必须指定我如何实现这个 trait。所以它只是变成，你知道，一堆块，非常冗长，而且泛型语法非常冗长。
But the fact that I can kind of write everything in one unit is nice. And in Rust, I have to say, okay, I've got a struct, and my struct just has data members and no methods on it. And then I have to write a separate block that's an implementation of that struct that provides the methods on my class. And then I want to say, oh, this thing is going to, you know, conform to a trait. Well, I have to say I'm implementing the trait for my class, and then I have to specify how I'm implementing the trait. So it just becomes, you know, a bunch of blocks and very verbose, and the generic syntax is very verbose.
而且，你知道，很多人抱怨借用检查器。老实说，我从来没有遇到过借用检查器的问题，但这是因为我无论如何都是用整体-部分关系来编写所有东西的。所以借用检查器，当它发挥作用时，只是语法噪音。我只需要说，你知道，tick A，tick A，tick A，tick A，这基本上是，你知道，我正在返回一个引用，而引用将指向我的参数之一，因为我遵循严格的整体-部分关系。或者我必须在泛型类型周围说 tick static，否则它无法编译，
And, you know, a lot of people complain about the borrow checker. Honestly, I've never had a problem with the borrow checker, but it's because I'm I write everything in terms of whole part relationships anyways. And so the borrow checker, when it does come into play, it's just syntactic noise. I just have to say, you know, tick A, tick A, tick A, tick A, which is basically, you know, I'm returning a reference and the reference is going to be to one of my arguments because I'm following strict whole part relationships. Or I have to say tick static around a generic type because otherwise it wouldn't compile
因为我正在把那个类型从作用域中取出来，而 Rust 有局部类型的概念。所以你必须说，不，不，不，那必须是一个全局类型。所以我基本上可以把它从作用域中取出来。那么，你是直接编写这些 Rust 代码，还是在使用 AI？我当然在使用 AI。我的意思是，我在 Cursor 和 Claude 上发现的一大优点是，我属于 Connor 阵营。这简直是火箭燃料。对于学习一个新系统，你知道，我，
because I'm taking that type out of a scope and Rust has a notion of local type. So you have to say, no, no, no, that has to be a global type. So I can basically take it out scope. Now, are you writing this Rust code with directly or are you using AI? I am certainly using AI. I mean, one of the great things that I have found with Cursor and Claude, I'm in kind of the Conner camp here. It's rocket fuel. And for learning a new system, you know, I,
我可以问，你知道，好吧，这是我想做的。我该怎么做？它会给我一个 Rust 代码块。现在，如果我不能立即理解那个 Rust 代码，那么我会去问问题，比如，你为什么要这样做？然后我通常会仔细检查这些信息，部分原因是我曾经被严重烧伤过，因为我问了一个关于 Rust 中的元组的问题，比如，假设我有一个 A, B 的元组。然后我有另一个元组是 A, B, C。问题是，Rust 中是否有保证前缀 A, B 在这两个元组之间具有相同的布局？因为我正在 Rust 内部做一点类型擦除和一点不安全代码，那个问题的答案非常重要。
I can ask, you know, okay, here's what I want to do. How do I do that? And it will give me a block of Rust code. Now, if I don't understand that Rust code immediately, then I will go and ask questions, like, why are you doing it this way? And then I will usually double-check that information, in part because I got burned badly once, because I asked a question about if a tuple in Rust, like, let's say I had a tuple of A, comma, B. And then I had another tuple that was A, comma, B, comma, C. The question was, is there a guarantee in Rust that the prefix A, B, has the same layout between those two tuples? And since I was doing a bit of hyperasure and a bit of unsafe code inside of Rust, the answer to that question was very important.
是的。我相信是 Claude 给了我一个非常漂亮的答案，关于为什么这是有保证的，带有逻辑和链接，你知道，它开头是，嗯，标准中没有明确说明，但它必须是真的，因为，你知道，A, B, C, D, E，非常有理有据，非常好。所以我按字面意思接受了它，并相应地实现了我的代码。两周后，我有一个非常难追踪的 bug。它花了我整整一周的时间，因为它是一个内存破坏者，你知道，在不安全代码中，去寻找出了什么问题。结果发现那不是一个真实的陈述。那些布局明确不保证匹配。它们只是碰巧通常匹配。所以我侥幸逃脱了。我回到我的标签页查看证明，实际上点击了所有的链接，
Yeah. And I believe it was Claude gave me a very beautiful. answer about why that was guaranteed with logic and links and, you know, it started with, well, it's not explicitly stated in the standard, but it must be true because, you know, A, B, C, D, E, very well-reasoned, very nice. And so I took that at face value and implemented my code accordingly. And two weeks later, I had a really hard bug to track down. and it took me a solid week because it's, you know, a memory stomper, you know, in unsafe code to hunt down what was going wrong. And it turns out that that is not a true statement. Those layouts are explicitly not guaranteed to match. They just happen to usually match. And so I got away with it. And I went back to my tab with the proof and actually clicked on all the list.
链接有一半根本打不开。这完全是幻觉胡扯。所以在那次经历之后，我对仅仅按字面意思接受事物更加谨慎了。是的，我从不信任它。我从不信任它。
links and half of them went nowhere. This is just total hallucination bullshit. So after that experience, I'm a bit more cautious with just accepting things at face value. Yeah, I never trust it. I never trust it.
你还记得是 3.5、3.7 还是 4.0 吗？可能是 3.5。那是在 4.0 之前。当然 4.0 一直更好。我仍然认为 Claude 4.0 我仍然认为比 GPT5 做得更好，
Do you remember what, was it 3.5, 3.7, 4.0? Probably 3.5. It was before 4.0. Certainly 4.0 has been nicer. I still think Claude 4.0 I still think does a better job than GPT5
尽管我喜欢 GPT5 的一点是它不会对你喷那么多烟雾，对吧？Claude 4.0 就像，嘿，那是一个很棒的问题。是的。无论你问什么，对吧？
although the one thing I do like about GPT5 is it doesn't blow so much smoke at you right, right? Cloud 4.0 is like, hey, that's a great question. Yeah. No matter what you ask, right?
它总是像，那是一个很棒的见解。让我去用那个很棒的见解把你所有的代码都搞乱。然后就像，不，那是一个糟糕的见解。我几乎不敢问它问题，我几乎不敢问它问题或提出建议，因为它就像我知道它会像
It's always like, that's a great insight. Let me go munge all of your code with that great insight. And it's like, no, that was a horrible insight. I'm almost afraid to ask it questions that I I'm almost afraid to ask it questions or make suggestions because it's like I know that it's going to be like
哦，就像我想让用户开心，所以我不会告诉他们不，我只会做他们建议的任何事情。是的，是的，GPT5 不会告诉你不，但它也不会因为你的无能而恭维你。我在这些 AI 系统中真正真正真正想要的一个功能是它们足够胜任，你知道，如果我说，嘿，你这样做怎么样，它会说，嗯，那是一个相当愚蠢的请求，因为那样做，你知道，它会与你说的你想要的其他事情相矛盾，或者它只会把事情搞砸，或者因为
oh like I want to make the user happy so I won't tell them no I'll just do whatever they suggest yeah yeah and GPG5 doesn't tell you no but it doesn't doesn't compliment you for your incompetence the one feature I really really really want in these AI systems is for them to be competent enough, you know, if I say, hey, how about you do it this way to go, to go, well, that's a pretty stupid request because that way, you know, it would contradict these other things that you said you wanted or it would just make a mess or for
任何原因，对吧？但它永远不会告诉你不。我刚刚意识到，也许这是我出于与编码不同的原因而磨练出来的一项技能，那就是我的未婚妻 Shima 和我经常，如果我们在某种事实问题上意见不一致，她会说，嗯，让我们问问 ChatGPT。起初我会说，当然，一个月后，我会说，不，亲爱的。我要问这个问题，因为你的问题带有诱导性。就像，它太诱导了。你在问题中放入了你想要的答案。
whatever reason, right? But it will never tell you no. I've only just realized now that maybe this is a skill that I have honed for different reasons than coding is that my fiance, say, Shima and I constantly, like, if we disagree on some kind of factual thing or whatever, she'll be like, well, let's just ask, you know, chat, GPT. And I'll be like, at first I'd be like, sure, a month later of that, I'd be like, no, sweetie. Like, I'm going to ask the question because you load your question. Like, it's so loaded. You put the answer that you want in your question.
然后她说，不，我没有。我说，好吧，问它和你说的相反的问题。然后，嗯，我不想问那个。因为那样，你知道，所以，如果你知道存在不确定性，比如，你不知道这是否是一个好主意或坏主意，是有办法的。我会明确地说，嘿，我正在寻找关于如何架构这一小部分的建议。给我五个不同的东西，告诉我你认为最好的是什么。而如果你已经有了，比如，哦，也许这很好，但我不知道。然后你问它，这是一个好主意吗？
And then she's like, no, I don't. And I was like, all right, well, ask it the opposite of what you said. And then, well, I don't want to ask it that. Because then, you know, so it's, there are ways where if you know there's uncertainty, like, you don't know if this is a good or bad idea. I will explicitly be like, hey, I'm looking for suggestions on how to architect this little piece. Like, give me five different things and tell me what you think the best is. Whereas if you already have like, oh, maybe this is good, but I don't know. And then you ask it, is it this a good idea?
它会说，当然，你可以这样实现它，即使它完全是错的。我从来没有意识到这也许是我秘密地或默默地在做的事情。而且这就像是一项磨练出来的技能，关于如何根据你的信心水平来提问。是的。我的意思是，当然，如果我没有，如果我很困惑，
It'll be like, sure, you can implement it like this, even if it's completely wrong. And I've never realized that that maybe is something I'm secretly or like silently doing. and that it's like it's a honed skill of like how to ask the question based on your confidence level of of what you're looking for. Yeah. And I mean, certainly if I'm not, if I'm confused,
对吧？而且我知道我很困惑。那么我会尝试说，说一些像，你知道，不要更改我的任何代码。这是我试图解决的问题。给我三个关于方法的建议。对吧？这真的很有用。
right, right? And I know I'm confused. Then I will try to say, say something like, you know, don't change any of my code. Here's the problem I'm trying to solve. Give me three suggestions on an approach. Right, right? And that can be really useful.
但有些时候，我像，哦，我只想添加这个功能。所以请添加这个功能。然后它就像，当然。然后它就摧毁了我所有的代码，你知道，生成了一堆错误。然后就像，哦，好吧，让我去修复那些错误。好吧，现在那个单元测试失败了。让我删除那个单元测试。
But it's the times where, where I'm like, oh, I want to just add this feature. So please just add this feature. And it's like, sure. And it just destroys all of my code and, you know, generates a bunch of errors. And it's like, oh, well, let me go fix those errors. Well, now that unit test is failed. Let me just remove that unit test.
然后它就失控了。好吧，你为什么不只是说，说，你知道，我可以那样做，但是。是的。我玩过像规则一样告诉它，比如不要，我最大的两个抱怨是当它做出，当它做出，当做出的更改不是我明确要求的事情时，比如我要求它做 X，它注意到了别的东西，它也试图做那件事，就像不，我告诉过你做这个，坚持做那个。然后第二件事是该死的注释，它添加了
And it just goes off. And it's, okay, how about you just say, say, you know, I could do that, but. Yeah. I've played around with like rules to tell. it like don't like the two of my two biggest gripes are when it makes when it makes uh when changes are made that were not things the thing that i explicitly requested like i asked it to do x and it noticed something else and it went to try to do that other thing too and it's like no i told you to do this just stick with that and then the second thing is freaking comments it adds
太多的注释，而且大多数是低质量的注释，所以我几乎，我几乎总是当我要求它做事情时，最后一句，好吧，就是没有注释。所以我的，是的，我前几天遇到的一个烦人的事情是，我让它把一个文件重构到一个单独的库中，并把它放在一个单独的库中。我希望它用 Doxygen 之类的东西设置好，C++ 库来构建文档。所以它完成了所有工作。我一看，文档是空的。我像，我像，哦，为什么会这样，对吧？因为我有所有的，在源文件中，我有所有的内联 Doxygen 注释。
so many comments and most of them are low quality comments so i almost i almost always when i'm asking it to do stuff like the last sentence all right is like no comment So my, yeah, an annoying thing I hit the other day is it's, it's, I had it refactor a file into a separate library and put it in a separate library. And I wanted it all set up with doxygen and stuff, C++ library to, to build a documentation. And so it does it all. And I look and the documentation is empty. And I'm like, I'm like, oh, why is this, right? Because I had all of, in the source file, I had all of the inline doxygen comments.
我去看了源文件，所有的 Doxygen 注释都被删除了，它只有一个非 Doxygen 注释，说这个文件是从另一个库移动过来的。我像，不。我发现对于像那样的某些任务，如果你问它，比如当你要求它重构代码时，如果你问它，嘿，比如移动这个文件，就像我试图把两个库合并在一起，类似的事情。要求它，比如，只把这个东西的函数拿出来放到另一个
and I go and I look at the source file, and all of the doxygen comments are stripped, and it's just got one non-doxygen comment that says, this file was moved from this other library. I'm like, no. I found that for some tasks like that, if you ask it, like when you're asking it to refactor code, if you ask it like, hey, like move this file, like this, like I was trying to merge two libraries together, a similar thing. And asking it, like, just take the functions from this thing and put it into this other
东西里。这对它来说真的很难。而对我来说，复制粘贴所有的函数并把它们扔进文件里，然后让它重构，这对我来说非常容易。但我认为发生的事情是，当你要求它，比如，把代码从一个地方移动到另一个地方，比如，它没有，至少它们中的一些没有，比如，做这件事的原生工具。所以这意味着它移动代码的方式是它在上下文中吞下它，然后它在输出中吐出它。这意味着你的代码正在通过，
thing. That was really tough for it. Whereas, like, for me, it was very easy for me to copy and paste all the functions and dump them into the file and then ask it to refactor it. But I think that what happens is when you ask it to, like, move code from one place to another, like, it doesn't, at least some of them don't have, like, a native tool for doing that. And so what it means is that the way that it's moving the code is it gobbles it up in the context, and then it spits it out in the output. And that means that your code is going through,
通过网络，当它这样做时，那些东西可能会发生。是的，就像，哦，让我读这段代码。现在让我试着凭记忆背诵它。是的。请务必查看这些节目笔记，在你的播客应用程序中或在 ADSP the podcast.com 上，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢并祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息点缀的混乱。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。
going through the network, and that stuff might happen to it when it does. Yeah, it's like, oh, let me read this code. Now let me try to recite it from memory. Yes. Yeah. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在网络中传输，当它传输时可能会发生这种情况。是的，就像是，哦，让我读一下这段代码。现在让我试着凭记忆背诵它。是的。是的。请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在您的播客应用程序中，还是在 ADSP the podcast.com 上，以获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论链接，您可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望您喜欢，祝您有愉快的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。那不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息点缀的混乱。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。